hey guys welcome back to my series
called introducing today is a special
episode today I'm leaving my comfort
zone of Western classical music and we
are heading east today we're going to
learn about the Arabic food
[Music]
so I am fascinated by the ode for a
number of reasons but mainly because the
OOD is the ancestor of the European and
loot that European loot by the 15th
century would fully blossom and become
one of the most important instruments of
the musical period we call the
Renaissance
[Music]
so in 711 the Moors who were the
inhabitants of northwest africa of the
time they decide to invade Spain and
when they did they brought with them the
in the Arabic world the oude was
commonly referred to as the king or the
Sultan of all instruments and in fact
boudoir allude in Arabic simply means
from wood so you know it's an instrument
made of wood
the oude is a likely descendant of an
ancient instrument called the Barbot
which was a persian instruments dated
back to something like 3500 years ago
now the earliest form of the oude would
have just four strings made of gut sheep
intestine right and over time over the
centuries they added more and more
strings until nowadays the common
stringing for an ood is 11 strings and
that's five doubled strings tuned in
Unison's and then one low string which
is single so for the tuning we have C
two FS two A's two DS two g's and two
seas so notice all the strings are tuned
in fourths perfect fourths except for
the F to the a which is a major third so
this instrument is played with a
plectrum or a pick right and this is
called a Risha which just means feather
and that's because the original
plectrums for this instrument would have
likely been an Eagles quill but today
often players just use plastic or a wood
like a piece of bamboo all ODEs
are hair
shaped on the soundboard and they
typically have three sound holes
sometimes they are full of incredibly
beautiful ornate decoration the back of
the instruments is always bowl shaped
and this is made up of individual strips
of wood called ribs usually made of a
hardwood which are heated up and bent
and glued together to make this gorgeous
shape here which also gives the
instrument its characteristic tone then
on top here we have a bent backwards peg
box which is quite beautiful and we have
friction pegs just like a violin these
pegs you just push in and turn and
that's what's that's what holds the
notes at pitch
the most interesting and distinguishing
part of this instrument for me as a
fretted player is that this doesn't have
any frets this is a fretless instrument
now at first it seems a bit daunting not
to have frets however it has its
advantages for example I can slide
between notes right I have no frets in
the way so I have infinite gradations
between each note and when I play a
melody instead of playing three distinct
pitches all the time I can for example
slide between them
which is if you listen to the music very
characteristic of that sound in the
beginning of this video I played a
Turkish song called you Scuderia darken
and the simple melody just sounds like
this but I was utilizing a lot of those
ornamental slides to make the sound the
song sound more vocal and in fact food
players are often meant to improvise
over the melodies to make them more
interesting so I came up with another
reason this instrument is fretless is in
order to play correctly all of the
varieties of McCollum's and amacom is
simply a scale there are roughly
something like a hundred regularly used
maqams in arabic music and when you
compare that to basically the seven
church modes that we use in western
classical music maybe plus the chromatic
scale in the whole tone scale it's
pretty pretty impressive
okay so let's hear some of these mcoms
the easiest one for me to wrap my head
around is called naho wand and that's
basically the Aeolian mode which is just
the minor scale so indeed and that's
actually the same scale I was using for
the Turkish tune boosts Ghidorah guitar
Canon and another maqam that I found
pretty relatable is called Kurd and
that's basically the Phrygian mode so
it's the same as the natural minor scale
the nowand macomb except there's an E
flat which makes it Phrygian so we have
E flat
Hey
[Music]
now here's where things get complicated
especially for me as a complete newbie
to the and Arabic music in general so
depending on which become you're using
you might have to use micro tones
microtones that exists in between the
western semitone the western scale is
basically an octave so exceed a C divide
it up into 12 half steps or semitones
each semitone is like one key on the
piano or one fret on the guitar but in
Arabic music certain Mekons use notes in
between those Western semitones so for
example if we take a a and then we use
b-flat that's about a Western semitone a
be half that would be sharp so something
around there and apparently depending on
which region you're from that'll
determine just how sharp or flat that
semitone is and I find that to be just
so cool it's so challenging to my ear
because it just sounds out of tune
because I'm only used to playing in the
western parameters but if we hear it in
context we can start to understand why
that can add some interesting flavor to
the music so here's here's the normal
b-flat and now the behalf flat
it actually makes a lot of sense to me
now when I hear it in context it doesn't
sound out of tune it just sounds kind of
like a different emotional effect my
favorite Macomb that I found so far is
called the high jaws and basically that
is d e half flat somewhere around there
so it's like a gun like a sharp E flat F
sharp B flat when I first heard that
scale I thought it kind of reminded me
of that that theme from pulp fiction
[Music]
if I decide to take this instrument
seriously and study it one of the
challenges would be memorizing a long
list of mcoms
and then being able to endlessly
improvise over any of them this is
another beautiful piece called halfoween
it uses the nahawand maqam which again
is basically Aeolian
[Music]
so bringing us into the 21st century the
OOD is no longer just an Arabic
instrument it comes in many shapes and
sizes and is played all around the world
in many different musical styles it's
such a beautiful versatile instruments
and if you are as fascinated about this
instrument and and its music as I am I
would strongly suggest that you listen
to some real good players I am just a
beginner on this instrument I have
officially taken one odd lesson but I am
just scratched the surface of the
capabilities of this instrument if you
want to hear what this beautiful
instrument can really do I suggest you
listen to some of the great hood players
of the world my favorite right now is H
an Asian food player named unorder ahem
there's also this fantastic Iraqi wood
player named Nasir Shama alright guys I
hope you enjoyed learning a bit about
the today with me if you haven't already
please do subscribe to this channel and
if you hit the bell notification you'll
get an email when I release my next
video of my introducing series so thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time
[Music]